nice hat oh thanks man  makes you look really cool thanks I bet  you get compliments all the time  sure do oh that's a great hat oh do you  think so it looks so good on you you  should totally buy it I don't know every  time I try something new my friends just  make fun of me  plus I don't think I'm a hat guy  I totally disagree I think your hat guy  let me think you look handsome and you  are all set Elijah thanks  I'm a head guy  Oh No hey you're talking to me hi I'm  Elliot hi how are you oh hey yep nice  head douche  hi hey guys yeah here we made a series  it's coming on November 18 please watch  it get it here yeah yeah over there man  you got it do you think you can see it  it'll be released 2015 November okay